en un partido un código de hecho usando
diferentes colores es creado por un
jugador el codificador y el otro jugador
intenta adivinar el código así que el
codificador da pistas sobre si los
colores son correctos y la posición es
correcta y los posibles colores son azul
déjame subrayar los colores con su
respectivo color azul amarillo blanco
rojo naranja y verde aunque el verde
esté escrito de ese mismo color lo vamos
a subrayar de todos modos así que
cuántos códigos de los cuatro colores
pueden hacerse o combinarse sin que los
colores sean repetidos de cierta forma
veamos que si vamos a elegir cuántos
colores existen son uno dos tres cuatro
cinco son seis colores y vamos a escoger
cuatro de ellos entonces cuántos códigos
de los cuatro colores pueden hacerse sin
que se repitan y dado que se trata de
códigos vamos a asumir que azul rojo
azul rojo amarillo amarillo y verde van
a ser diferentes a tener el siguiente
código verde
rojo
amarillo
y azul y cuando asumimos que no son el
mismo código pues a pesar de que se han
escogido los mismos cuatro colores vamos
a asumir que estos son dos códigos
diferentes lo cual tiene sentido pues
estamos hablando de los códigos así que
estos son diferentes por tanto estos
serían dos códigos diferentes a pesar de
que hemos escogido los mismos colores
inicialmente los mismos cuatro colores
hemos escogido en diferente orden ahora
vamos a pensar en cuántas maneras
diferentes podemos elegir dichos cuatro
colores así que vamos a decir que aquí
tenemos cuatro ranuras o cuatro espacios
y en primer lugar nos vamos a preocupar
de cuántas maneras podemos escoger un
color para cada línea entonces tomando
en cuenta que aún no hemos elegido color
y que tenemos seis diferentes colores
nos van a dar entonces seis diferentes
posibilidades para esta línea de aquí
ellos nos dicen que los colores no se
pueden repetir por lo que cualquier
color que ya esté en esta línea no lo
vamos a considerar en los próximos
colores posibles por lo que si ya hemos
tomado este color cuantas posibilidades
son cuando pasamos a esta segunda línea
y bien tomamos uno de los seis para la
primera línea entonces aquí nos quedan
cinco posibilidades y con la misma
lógica cuando vamos a la tercera línea
hemos utilizado ya dos de los colores
anteriores por lo que serían ahora
cuatro colores posibles y finalmente por
la última línea ya han pasado tres de
los posibles colores por lo que son tres
posibilidades entonces si pensamos en
todas las posibilidades en todas las
permutaciones son cuando pensamos en
todas las posibilidades pero cuidando el
orden donde te dice que este código es
diferente a este otro y esto es a lo que
se le conoce como una permutación así
que aquí todas las permutaciones que
tenemos son seis para la primera cinco
para la segunda
para la tercera y tres para nuestra
cuarta posición entonces 6 por 5 son 30
luego por 4 por 3 4 por 3 son 12 así que
30 por 12 esto serían 360 permutaciones
y listo esto es